[Aplausos]
muchas gracias por la invitación les
quiero contar ya que muchos ustedes son
universitarios como era mi vida en la
universidad recuerdo como si fuera ayer
a pesar de que fue hace como 12 años que
en mis primeras clases de la universidad
me presentaron un gráfico que mostraba
los avances de la humanidad y mostraba
como en los últimos 200 años el pp y el
crecimiento económico se había disparado
y con eso se había más que duplicado la
expectativa de vida y se había reducido
a la tercera parte la mortalidad
infantil por lo clarito que están y
primeras clases la universidad y pensar
qué suerte tengo de estar viviendo en
una época en la que la humanidad está
prosperando en el que la humanidad es
exitosa además la universidad tenía un
cartel entrando en la puerta que decía
atrévete a ser empresario
mi papá es empresario mi abuelo
empresario el cartel me decía que fuera
empresario estaba tenía que hacer
una empresa
me fui a la notaría y comencé una
empresa además con esta mirada de que la
humanidad había crecido y había resuelto
tantos problemas como la mortalidad
infantil a raíz del crecimiento
empresarial que tengo que admirar a los
grandes empresarios me pasaba como como
un viendo en vivo las
presentaciones de steve jobs de cómo
presentaba no sé el ipod touch o algo
así y los veía en vivo y decía increíble
este empresario las cosas que está que
está logrando antes fui a la notaría con
mis amigos y comenzamos una empresa no
sabíamos ni siquiera de que iba a ser
reemplazo a lo que queríamos era tener
nuestra empresa
y muy pronto quizás con un poco de
suerte también a la empresa le comenzó a
ir bien comenzó a recibir
reconocimientos por ejemplo los
profesores con los que nos llevábamos
muy mal en en la universidad nos
comenzaron a felicitar en la clase
teníamos examen nos decían que podíamos
dar un ensayo o una entrevista en lugar
del examen porque éramos empresarios
a mí que las chicas nunca me habían
mirado en la vida de pronto me
comenzaron a mirar porque la empresaria
yo estaba demasiado feliz llegaba el
almuerzo familiar los domingos
mi abuelo empresario de noventa y tantos
años me felicitaba por ser empresario
entonces maravilloso teníamos a la
humanidad exitosa con el gráfico de la
mortalidad infantil teníamos a los
grandes empresarios trabajando al
servicio del éxito de la humanidad y
teníamos además yo el exitoso empresario
todos felices
- yo sí les confieso algo en todo ese
tiempo yo tenía como una especie de
insatisfacción subyacente
yo quería más reconocimiento cualquier
resultado empresarial que consiguiera no
no me era suficiente
y no sólo eso sino que además tenía un
contraste muy fuerte con mi hermano
mayor que unos años antes había como
renunciado a la ciudad y se había ido a
vivir a lunahuaná al lado del río a una
comunidad en la que consume aquello que
siembra donde se bañan todo el dia
kalathos en el río
y mi hermano am lo veo siempre muy feliz
tiene una mirada y una energía y una
onda de mucha alegría y yo siempre está
estresado con las ventas y los clientes
italia pero pero soy empresario pero
estoy trabajando al servicio de lo que
me enseñaron en la universidad y comencé
entonces a investigar un poquito en
internet de donde viene verdaderamente
la felicidad y curiosamente me encontré
con un con un texto que seguramente
algunos de ustedes han visto sobre los
orígenes de la felicidad y lo que la
ciencia en los últimos años ha comenzado
a describir como fuente de felicidad y
la felicidad en realidad no viene de ir
a la notaria y comenzar una empresa y la
felicidad no viene de tener un nuevo
cliente ni tener un nuevo inversionista
la felicidad viene de las comunidades de
las que somos parte de los propósitos a
los que verdaderamente servimos
y entonces
en esa misma línea comencé a pensar no
solamente que yo no estaba siendo
verdaderamente exitoso sino que estaba
contando una historia que me habían
contado a mí antes
y no solamente eso sino que además ese
éxito empresarial ese vídeo que veía de
steve jobs en vivo tenía también unas
externalidades negativas que por algún
motivo no estamos queriendo ver no
quiero decir con esto que las empresas
no tengan un poder de convocatoria un
poder de escala un poder de mercado que
seguramente puede lograr grandes cosas
pero las externalidades negativas como
que no las vemos y les pongo un ejemplo
con una de las marcas más conocidas del
mundo que es coca cola coca-cola
seguramente le da trabajo a cientos de
miles de personas en el mundo directa e
indirectamente cocacola seguramente
tributa miles de millones de dólares en
casi todos los países del mundo sino en
todos
pero cuántas de las botellas de plástico
que hay en el mar
fueron una botella de coca-cola en su
momento o cuántos niños tuvieron en
algún momento tienen un problema de
salud producto de que estuvieron tomando
coca cola desde los 3 o 4 años como a
veces veo en los aeropuertos
entonces tenemos que aprender a
reconocer que las empresas en sí mismas
no importa cuánto vendan no son exitosas
sino que tenemos que ver el impacto que
va más más allá
ahora les he dicho que ser empresario no
es necesariamente sinónimo de ser
exitoso les he dicho que las empresas
grandes las empresas más conocidas
tampoco son necesariamente exitosas e
incluso esto me ha llevado a cuestionar
ese gráfico que me enseñaron en el
primer ciclo de la universidad del éxito
de la humanidad y para eso quiero que
hagamos un ejercicio solamente voy a
parar 10 segundos
acabamos de deforestar juntos 9.000
árboles
en esos 10 segundos acabamos de matar
para el consumo humano a 437.000
animales que además fueron criados y
mantenidos en situaciones muy crueles
pero la humanidad es exitosa
pero el gráfico dice que estamos
creciendo que estamos incrementando la
expectativa de vida
entonces me hubiera encantado que ese
gráfico fuera diferente me hubiera
encantado que quizás no estemos
comparando crecimiento con respectiva de
vida sino que estuviéramos comparando
por ejemplo felicidad humana contra
sufrimiento de otros seres ahí en este
gráfico como que la curva no está tan
clara no más bien la ciencia
pareciera decirnos que no solamente no
estamos más felices estamos además
expuestos continuamente a unas redes
sociales en las que pareciera que nunca
llegamos a obtener suficiente dopamina
tenemos que poner algo más y que si es
que no estamos comiendo un ceviche
tenemos que tomarle una foto porque si
no el sitio no existe y si vamos a
correr más vale que subamos cuántos
kilómetros hemos corrido porque si no
nos corrimos realmente
entonces pareciera que la humanidad en
realidad no tiene esa curva tan clara de
éxito que me describieron en mis
primeras clases de la universidad como
podemos decir que la humanidad está
siendo más exitosa si no está siendo más
feliz y está impartiendo un sufrimiento
creciente a los seres que tiene a su
alrededor como podemos decir que la
humanidad está siendo exitosa
ahora qué mensaje de parece que
le he traído hoy día qué mensaje de
desesperanza para nada hoy día yo lo que
les quiero traer es todo lo contrario es
un mensaje
de esperanza es un mensaje que parta de
reinterpretar lo que entendemos como
éxito tanto a nivel personal a nivel
empresarial y a nivel de toda la
humanidad y es un trabajo que cada uno
tiene que hacer en su tiempo yo por
ejemplo considero que soy exitoso no
necesariamente cuando gano un nuevo
cliente o cuando tengo un nuevo
inversionista sino por ejemplo cuando
paseo por acá por barranco con mis
perros en silencio tranquilo a mí me
encanta levante la mano a quienes le
gustan los perros
sólo por curiosidad aquí me gustan los
gatos retírense por favor del auditorio
aprender a valorar ese momento anónimo
de estar con mis perros por ejemplo eso
para mí es ese éxito y con esto no
quiero enaltecer la inacción no hay nada
vayan a pasear sus perros y todo lo que
hemos escuchado hoy día olvídense lo no
hay nada no quiero decirles eso pero sí
que sí es que finalmente deciden hacer
empresas deciden construir una
organización o sumarse a una
organización que lo hagan no desde el
deseo de la dopamina del reconocimiento
del éxito o del absurdo de la
acumulación yo quiero tener tantos
millones a tal edad
cuando el mundo tiene 14 mil millones de
años y tú vas a vivir 50 70 o 100
qué importa dese cuenta de lo
irrelevante que es y de lo poco
razonable que esté invirtamos nuestro
tiempo lejos de las cosas que
verdaderamente nos generan una
satisfacción y en esa línea
junto a otros amigos y por nuestro amor
por los perros comenzamos esta
organización good para ayudar a los
perros para darles una empresa a los
perros para crearles productos a los
perros y que con esos
con esos productos luego podamos
construir un mundo mejor para ellos y
esa empresa no nos paga ni un sol no
tenemos ni sueldo ni dividendos ni
acciones en nada pero si nos remunera
hay una gran diferencia entre que algo
no te pague y algo no te remunere para
mí no hay mayor satisfacción que la
remuneración que me da cuando pagamos lo
que llamamos los dividendos caninos y
vamos y les repartimos comida a perros
que se han rescatado de la calle y así
como buf hay organizaciones en todo el
mundo y también acá en el perú que están
comenzando a priorizar el impacto y la
trascendencia que generan por sobre los
resultados humanos de corto plazo hoy
decir que una empresa existe para
generar rentabilidad es anacrónico es
medieval
tenemos que estar verdaderamente al
servicio de la humanidad y la humanidad
pienso ojala compartan esto conmigo
tiene el potencial de reinventarse tiene
el potencial de transformarse hacia una
humanidad más despierta una humanidad
más consciente una humanidad más
empática con los demás seres
la humanidad en el que cada individuo
encuentre un éxito genuino cada
organización sirva para el éxito de la
humanidad y una humanidad en la que no
solamente sus individuos sean más
felices sino que además no le importa
daño al resto en mi opinión y ojalá la
compartan conmigo recién entonces
podremos hablar de que somos exitosos
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]